[Música]
una semana más les doy la bienvenida
cultura de france 24 en concreto al
poder del cómic y es que en países bajos
un historiador hay o por azar las
primeras viñetas que retrataron los
campos de concentración nazis y el
exterminio de las cámaras de gas en los
40 ya se intuía el horror en escritos y
trazados pero fue august folio quien en
1944 ha apoyado en crónicas desde el
ejército soviético lo dibujo con mayor
detalle y haciendo comprensible el
holocausto
este relato se caricaturizó en paralelo
al nazismo mientras que en españa contra
pasó hace de la historieta un rescate de
la postguerra y el régimen franquista no
suficientemente ilustrados sus efectos
con abusos médicos folletos clandestinos
y demandas de libertad persisten y aquí
se plasman en dos periodistas que dan
color a la oscuridad de la dictadura
y vemos a lo que buscaba tom taylor con
un superman bisexual no jugará el truco
sino hacer de jong hijo de clark kent un
superhéroes real dentro de dizzy comics
con luchas climáticas y por refugiados
actuales los creadores por ello han sido
amenazados de muerte lo que no impide
que el hijo de un extraterrestre y de
lois lane vaya a estar en librerías
[Música]
han sido honestamente han sido
abrumadoramente positivas deseaban que
superman fuera esto cuando estaban
creciendo que pudieran verse a sí mismos
y por primera vez se están viendo a sí
mismos en superman o algo que nunca
pensaron que fuera posible no queríamos
que esto fuera dis y cómics crea un
nuevo superman queer queremos que sea
superman se encuentra a sí mismo se
convierte en superman y luego sale del
armario y creo que esa es una distinción
realmente importante para su misterioso
joven tim wright no se inspiró en
viñetas pero se acerca el universo de
stephen king al que muy pronto adaptarán
el cineasta de baby driver y la trilogía
del core neto demuestra en las night in
soho estar listo para un terror
psicológico a la altura de clásicos
tipos suspiria aunque dándole una vuelta
de inspiración es más sesentera como
repulsión es a esos años que envía a
eloise tomasín mckenzie una joven que se
va a londres para estudiar moda pero
cuyos sueños la multa de en sandy han ya
taylor joy una cantante y bailarina que
igual busca triunfar en los 60 la
dicotomía sojo divertido barra lleno de
cadáveres es espeluznante como el
cuestionamiento de la realidad y la
transformación actoral esta es el buen
estilo write se apoya en planos
coreografía 2 y luces retro con los que
no querrán soñar
con 10
consigue peces
[Música]
esta noche sprint
m
[Aplausos]
el diseño
en otras noticias un thriller es lo que
está viviendo la orquesta sinfónica de
líbano que ante la tesitura de
interpretar piezas de conjunto o
recortada se siente en el titanic la
crisis económica por años de corrupción
e inacción política ha llevado a migrar
a muchos músicos mientras otros
contienen el naufragio cual banda ante
el glaciar por ahora siguen pero sin un
repertorio y un sueldo que apenas cubre
el combustible los conciertos podrían
pasar de desolación a clausura
i
[Música]
para más inri y la música se está viendo
afectada por la crisis mundial de
suministros y tras el papel es el turno
de los discos y vinilos los de abba
están protegidos tranquilos aunque
después de 40 años mejor no esperar su
sorprendente y ya de colección guayas es
literal un viaje al cuarteto que fueron
antes del álbum the visitors que marcó
su última aparición nunca nombraron la
ruptura pero en silencio sembré un
regreso al estudio ya la música a la que
tenía un fe pues así suenan optimistas
melódicos disco como si el tiempo y las
tendencias nunca hubieran pasado
han pasado cuatro décadas desde la
última vez que lanzaron un disco pero
ahora sigue sonando a los fanáticos ya
saborean esta nostalgia en guayas
el disco fue anunciado en redes sociales
junto con planes para un espectáculo
pero los hologramas reemplazarán a las
estrellas quienes han asegurado que
jamás volverán a actuar en vivo se
necesitaron cinco semanas de capturas de
movimiento para obtener los efectos
correctos
we found descubrimos que sería posible
ya que los hologramas son una tecnología
antigua
y queríamos hacerlo antes de morir o
vivir con waterloo ava ganó el concurso
eurovisión y luego conquistó el mundo
con éxitos pegadizos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero a pesar de su éxito profesional sus
vidas personales fueron tensas las dos
parejas de la banda se divorciaron y el
grupo dejó de divertirse en
1982 pero sus seguidores nunca los
olvidaron
50 años después de su formación con el
álbum y una gira 2022 será otro año pop
para el del fin de su historia
como cierre es nuestro deber invocar a
la joven artista brasileña marilia
mendoza fallecida el 5 de noviembre de
estrellarse su avioneta camino a un
concierto nuestro tributo es su ser tan
el yo de mujeres su poderío y su
irrupción en el country nacional bañado
de machismo en brasil cuídense y
muchísimas gracias
ugarte
he dejado
hacer lo que sentía
y todo aprovecha aquí alanís hoy
[Música]
sabor
acá